what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for a season 7 update video some
breaking news was just released by
watches on the wall that is pretty
exciting if you ask me the titles for
the first three episodes of season 7
have officially been released plus each
of the episodes have a brief description
as well so let's take a look at each of
the episode names and see if we can
figure out what may or may not be taking
place in them also feel free to comment
down below if you have some good ideas
now let's get started season 7 episode 1
is titled Dragonstone in the description
for the episode says Jon Snow who
organized the defenses of the north
Circe he's going to try to even the odds
and Daenerys comes home Daenerys coming
home is pretty simple
she's going to arrive on Dragonstone in
the very first episode which is very
exciting because we will finally have
Daenerys in Westeros surrounded by the
main cast I know I've been waiting for
this day to come for a very long time
now it also says John's going to
organize the defenses of the north I'm
hoping John makes arrangements to man
the wall there are a shitload of empty
castles along the wall that need men not
to mention Castle black has a skeleton
crew of less than about 50 men right now
they are nowhere near prepared for an
attack on the wall if the knight King
just decided to show up right now John
desperately needs to figure that out and
get men and weapons to the wall as soon
as possible we know from previous
reports John's going to hold a meeting
where he tells everyone that they need
to get dragonglass and that it's worth
more than gold right now
John organizing the defenses for the
north could also have something to do
with figuring out what to do with the
Karstark and numbers land and the
dreadfort
he could end up putting some wildlings
in some of those lands in the north and
it also says Cersei will try and even
the odds in episode 1 I'm not exactly
sure what that means yet I still need a
little bit more time to think about this
stuff but it could have to do with the
septa bail or gray area actually said
Cersei may try and lie her way out of
being blamed for the set blowing up and
if that's the case and Cersei lies about
who used the wildfire
we could see her plane to attack someone
else that she blames or this might be
when Jaime and Cersei decide they're
going to attack Highgarden
we know from plenty of reports and
photos that Jamie is going to go down to
Highgarden and basically conquer it so
this could be them planning how they're
going to strike but comment down below
and let me know what you think it means
by evening the odds Cersei may also be
aware of Daenerys
in Dragonstone with a huge army so
Cersei may have a plan to get more
people on her side and even the odds net
way by making her army much larger but
it's hard to really say right now this
could mean so many different things but
it definitely has me intrigued as to
what it means exactly but let's move on
episode 2 episode 2 is titled Stormborn
in the description for this episode says
Daenerys receives an uninspected visitor
John faces a revolt in Tyrion plans the
conquest of Westeros this is a very
interesting description who the hell
could Damaris be meeting that's an
unexpected visitor because I'm assuming
John is still going to be in the north
at this point since it says he faces
overvote unless it's happening behind
his back while he's meeting Daenerys and
I'm also assuming Jorah Mormont will
show up a Dragonstone soon but I don't
think he's going to be cured and on
Dragonstone by episode 2 that would be
pretty damn fast but the producers also
said this season is going to move at a
crazy speed so it could be jor showing
up on Dragonstone already this could
also be the scene from the trailer when
we see Daenerys on the back of her
dragon if you look behind her you can
see dragon stones castle in the back so
I wonder if this is her meeting this
unexpected visitor so she intimidates
them with her dragon but who do you
think it could be it could also be
Melisandre we did see Melisandre on
Dragonstone in the trailer she could
arrive in episode 2 but it also says
Jon's going to face a revolt in episode
2 now this is interesting this may have
something to do with the Karstark a
number of children if you've been
staying up to date this offseason then
you know at some point early this season
Jon will have to make a decision what to
do with the Karstark in numbers since
they turn their back on the Starks and
fought for ramsay apparently Jon doesn't
want to punish them but Songza and
Lyanna Mormont want to hold them
accountable for their parents mistakes I
can definitely see this causing some
tension between all the other
northerners they've also been hyping up
a power struggle between Jon and Sansa
sons and they feel like things need to
be done her way while Jon wants to do
everything his way there have also been
a few photos released in a few short
clips in the trailer of a meeting being
held in the main hall at Winterfell so
this may have something to do with that
but last but not least it says Tyrion
will plan the conquest of Westeros in
the trailer there was a scene of someone
knocking over the lion in Casterly Rock
on the big table
app that is in Stannis's old war room
this is most likely tearing and
explaining to Damaris how they can cut
off Casterly Rock Daenerys is going to
hold a big meeting in this room as well
with several other characters will they
will begin to plan the invasion of
Westeros there should be pretty damn
exciting because they're ready to get to
work right away episode 3 is titled the
Queen's justice and that's a dope-ass
title the description says Daenerys
holds court which is exactly what I was
just talking about according to one of
the reports that was released Daenerys
will hold a meeting in this war room and
apparently there's going to be several
other main players here with her and
Tyrion planning their next moves it also
says in this episode that Cersei is
going to return a gift and Jamie's going
to learn from his mistakes I can only
make assumptions as to what the hell
this could mean since there are only
seven episodes this season they're going
to need to move pretty fast and since we
know Jaime will be in a few different
battles this season he must be leaving
King's Landing by now not only will he
conquer Highgarden but he's also going
to get ambushed by the Dothraki on his
way home so he should be leaving King's
Landing by Episode three if he hasn't
left already
this may be the gift they are referring
to when it says Cersei returns a gift
Jaime might be at Highgarden by this
time meeting face to face with Lady
Olenna
what if Cersei sends Margaery and Norris
his body's home with Jaime to deliver to
Lady Olenna that would be pretty damn
[ __ ] up but it also says Jamie learns
from his mistakes
I wonder if Cersei tried to manipulate
him in some way but he tells himself not
to fall for it this time I'm not really
sure about this I'm going to need your
feedback on this one so let me know down
below what do you think about the titles
for the first three episodes and also
let me know what you think some of these
descriptions may mean I'm sure some of
you have a good angle on some of this
stuff - thanks for stopping by and
watching the video I hope you enjoyed
this quick update about the first story
episodes the season premiere is so close
the anticipation is sort of roof right
now I cannot wait to start watching some
new episodes I hope you all come along
for the ride because I'll be making all
kinds of different videos each week
during the season and I also want to
give a quick shout out to my patreon
supporters thank you all so much for the
help that you have contributed to the
channel it really means a lot to me I
love you all and I'll see you down below
I